Film Courage: Why do philosopher’s love death?
Robert Rippberger, Filmmaker: It's a
good question as to why philosophers love
death and it's essentially because it's a main
orientation point for meaning because faced with
ultimate loss it then asks you well what is
important while you're alive? So facing death,
facing finitude or your own mortality then becomes
a central sort of way to frame yeah what is it
what is a good life and I think certainly a lot
of people are curious about that what does it mean
to have a good death it's a good question about
what it means to have a good death there's it's
been a fascination of a lot of philosophers
of well it's to be surrounded by people and
it's to be have a legacy and and I think a
lot of cynics have also there's a book about
all of the ridiculous ways that people have died
and so I think that largely has has become more of
a a sort of joke within philosophy of that that
there's all this Obsession about having a a a
good death and ultimately what does it amount
to and what does it really matter why does it
really matter I forget who it was but there
was a general who was really trying to have
this good death and and he was he was bleeding
out and he was trying to get all of his men to
come together before before he passed and they
weren't coming together fast enough and he knew
he was gonna die and he just blurted tell them I
said something great and then died and so I think
stories like that seem to have kind of taken
the main that it's like well let's talk about
life itself rather than what it is to die
because you really have no control over it
if someone has a story idea and they never write
that story does their story idea even matter
it's a good question if somebody
has a story idea I would say
it just made it seem harsh but I would say it
doesn't matter I think ultimately what's real
is what you put into the world and but even if you
just write it down right like Emily Dickinson she
had hundreds of thousands of poems that never were
published but once she passed people found them
and then those were out into the world and those
took on and and a whole kind of world of meaning
was built around her and and what she created and
so I really am a strong advocate of always putting
things down and taking action and and creating
because that's if it's just in your head then
it's it's it's not it's not yet in the world and
so I always try to get as much out out as possible
is that something that plagued you
because it sounds like you've always
had these these ideas or or been drawn to
things that were maybe ahead of your time
I think for me yeah there was a sense early on of
what it is to be great and to have a legacy and
and certainly to sort of like establish yourself
and and sort of beget success from that and so
but I think as far as kind of linking with ideas
ahead of my time or I think it was more always
came from within is like what is it that I want
to say and I want these paths to open up further
for me so that there's less inhibitions that I
can write down an idea and then go to investors
and get a project going and just kind of move
move move because there's never a shortage of
of ideas for the next film and there's probably
15 projects that I've got Brewing at different
stages and so it's more a bit about sort of how
to converge that momentum in order to yeah be be
out there more in the world and expressing and
working with people that I love to work with
when you were studying philosophy at UC Berkeley
was that your goal then to go into directing and
producing films or did you not know exactly what
you wanted to do I always knew I was a storyteller
and that that was my path in my life and and
specifically studying philosophy at Berkeley
was to understand the power of story and
I had I loved horror films and so I kind
of asked like well is that what I'm gonna do is
just make horror films while climate change and
all these other things are happening and it was
philosophy that sort of regrounded the value and
kind of went back to the very basic questions
of faced with these problems what can one do
and sort of allowed me to sort of rebuild my sort
of world of meaning and sort of get more concrete
on values and to better understand the the power
of story and that was through existentialists and
read a bunch of Dostoevsky and Kirkegaard and
and and then I came back and I was like okay
I feel like now there's I'm not I'm not waiting
in the water that there's a solid infrastructure
around me that I can I can build future
projects and build build my career on top of
why not go to film school and just learn how to
write the next fun teen comedy I had made so I
started making films really in like elementary
school and then so by the time I was in college
I had well by the time I was in high school I
had already been taking film classes at college
learned screenwriting and production and just kind
of basic things and I was enormously self-taught
so every documentary about filmmaking every behind
the scenes I could get my hand on commentaries
and so then when it turned to going to film school
I felt like it was doubling up and I also took
umbridge that the schools sometimes own your
films and I thought why am I going to pay a
massive amount of tuition to also pay to make
my own films if I feel like I already have that
knowledge and it felt like it was doubling
up so I thought how can I sort of extend my
knowledge of filmmaking and storytelling
and and that led me to philosophy what
differentiates a movie that has a great message
a good message from a movie that's too preachy
a film that's too preachy I think can be too just
heavy-handed on an audience and essentially your
immediate reaction is is like well you've it
feels more like a rhetorical argument it feels
like you're at dinner and somebody's saying
like you should believe this whereas a film
that I think just has a message is for me kind of
like interacting it with somebody at dinner and
they're saying like well this these are the things
that are important to me and these are the this is
the way I see the world and and this is the way
I think one might consider a situation like this
versus do this be that and and so that
in my films while they do have messages
I'm always very conscious of not
having it to be too heavy-handed
how does a movie effectively present a point
without insulting the intelligence of the audience
I mean in in any film as a director you're
always asking yourself okay this is this
is what I'm showing visually and what is
the audience going to take away from that
and I always try to assume that the that the
audience is is smarter than I am and not kind
of hand feed them things certainly there's
parts where if you need to connect dots but
I always assume that people will be smart enough
to get things and if they aren't then they'll ask
the per the person next to them in the theater and
it I do really think it's it's important to not
speak down to your audience or or to be be too
kind of heavy-handed in in storytelling because
it can easily lead to an eye roll which then
pulls people out and I would rather people be
asking and engaging and sort of drawing people
further in together about hey can you clarify
this can you clarify that rather than saying
well I feel like I'm in a in a film that's
that's for kindergartners or something like that
sure so it may be better to leave with a sense of
mystery where where there's like people can't
exactly figure out there's an ambiguity to it
yeah so I watched a ton of Sydney Lumet's voice so
I watched a town of Sydney Lumet's commentaries he
actually has a commentary for every single film
he's ever made and one point that comes up over
and over and over is the cutaway is say you have
somebody who really wants to be invited to a party
and they get an invitation and they open it do
you cut away to the invitation or do you say
the audience is smart enough they know that
he opens the envelope and he's been invited
and so that level of of distinction and I'm on
I'm on the same camp is that you don't have to
spoon feed every bit of information the audience
is very smart and will be with you and so then you
can move on to the next scene where he's actually
at the party because we we get the point right can
you explain how stacking the deck in favor of a
message is cheating the audience and how stacking
the deck against your message is challenging the
audience and ultimately hitting deeper truths
so in constructing a film that ultimately
has a message and you're wanting to
I feel like if you're wanting
to sort of lead the witness or
philosophical terms like use a straw man argument
that it is pretty disingenuous because essentially
we all know why leading the witness is is not a
great idea but I think in filmmaking you can run
into a similar concern where if you want to show
somebody something there's so many ways to do that
there's so many brilliant films that that do
that but if you're wanting the film to draw
a conclusion then if for me it sometimes
just feels like a bit disingenuous a bit
like a rhetorical argument rather than having
a conversation it feels again like being a bit
condescending to the audience that you can kind
of trick them into thinking this or that and
I just feel like it's in in bad faith and so in
constructing narratives I'm always sensitive to
to that point as well that you're you're
not manipulating and that you're not doing
anything further than saying consider this and
and see this and step into this this other world
has that happened where you've you have footage
you have a rough cut on the editing timeline and
you realize oh no this is this is a rhetorical
question and we've got to go in and and fix it
or or is that something that you be that you're
they're cognizant of when you're shooting and it
doesn't normally happen generally it's in the way
the film is structured or framed in the beginning
but it certainly can come out in nuanced decisions
as we're working through in our film seven days in
Syria for example we were conscious that we're
really showing one side and that was because we
didn't have access to the other side and so we
we put little bits and pieces in the film itself
to acknowledge that and and just kind of cue
to the audience that like you're seeing this
perspective you're not seeing the perspective from
the other side and that was just again to sort of
give give proper context to an educated audience
about about how to interpret and watch this film
because essentially it was a story of a female
journalist who wanted to go over there and was
told don't do it yeah and and but essentially
we also were on the free Syrian Army side so
it was mainly the the rebel Army that was going
against this very dictator dictatorial regime
and the troubling statistic was that 80 percent
of of Syria at the time was in favor of the of
this dictatorial regime which is just killing
people left and right who are opposing them
and so but that wasn't our full perspective
we were to sort of walk you into a window
into this other world and what it is
what it's like to live during wartime
I believe some of the footage was from other
people's cell phones and you you gave credit to
them yeah exactly so we we pulled basically when
we were in Aleppo there were different people that
we met along the way and then we incorporated
their footage as well other other journalists
other people that were just civilians and use that
to kind of build a more holistic picture of of
of what life in in Aleppo before it had fallen was
was like and did anybody say anything about they
felt it was one-sided or not certainly there's
certainly there's some comments online and not
with my film but basically pro-Russian pray
Pro Syrian people have tried to hack accounts
for their film and tried to try to disparage it
in all these different ways because eventually
essentially what you're there is you're showing
what it's like to be a human being and those
who are trying to oppress those human beings
are usually at least in these cases backed by
governments and have their own budgets and
they sometimes do that to try and censor.